bind has suggested expanding a program  that forgives the loans of people who  work in public service while this may  sound like a noble idea the  beneficiaries include some extremely  high paid professionals working at  non-profit hospitals like cardiologists  who make four hundred thousand dollars a  year on average  public service workers often have the  best job security health care and  pension benefits among middle-class  workers making them strange candidates  for debt forgiveness why should students  worry about staggering loan balances if  the government is just gonna cancel the  debt anyway it only discourages them  from taking a more prudent path like  attending affordable community colleges  before enrolling in a four-year  university or going to a trade school  that arms students with practical skills  that lead to high paying in-demand jobs  if colleges notice that high tuition is  scaring off would-be students they'd  have to lower their prices  [Music]  you